as this gruesome war enters its sixth
month people living on the front line in
the donbass fear the shelling will never
end
[Applause]
in the city of solidar they only leave
their apartment blocks now for
emergencies
the streets are deserted
and it is easy to see why
[Music]
very close
there is no power or water here and
residents are terrified surviving next
to their bomb shelters
[Music]
[Music]
everyone
they don't know here
winning this war they just want the
fighting to stop
[Music]
but this war is not about to end
as we make our way to the ukrainian
military frontline positions it's clear
this conflict could go on for years
as mikulavich guides us he warns there
could be incoming fire
the line of contact stretches for miles
and both sides are heavily dug in
yes
ukraine says western long-range
artillery is slowly giving them the
advantage
this is one of the frontline positions
north of sloveansk and you can get an
idea of the kind of territory they're
fighting across
that's the saversky donetsk river
they're using it as a natural defensive
barrier
but here they are very very close to
their russian enemy
the russians are just the other side now
about 700 meters away
it is hard to know whether ukraine is
capable of victory or is just losing
slowly
russia is finding it difficult but is
making gains in the east
and you only have to visit the cities in
the firing line to see that
bakmoot is slowly being crushed
nearly every day shells and rockets are
landing here
traumatizing the local population
hi how are you
ruslan says he wants ukraine to win but
more than that he wants peace and
stability even if it means conceding
territory
[Music]
this is what's left of the local school
smashed in an air strike
there are reminders of what life was
once like here
but now there is only the sound of
violence as russia's assault gets closer
alex rossi sky news
eastern ukraine